i know that you're in london now are you
going to celebrate
christmas in london or mexico city
no i mean i i have to pretend i love
being in london in winter but no one
saying can
actually say that you know it's painful
it's
i mean it's a beautiful city to watch
from your window but uh it gets really
cold and wet
uh at least for for a mexican is it's
not probably the best so i'm flying back
home
as soon as we finish uh uh to spend the
holidays
not just that it's not just the weather
uh
you know my family is there i wanna with
this pandemic it's like
there's no time off i don't wanna be
next to my kids my
dad my friends yeah yeah reminds you
what really matters you know
i'm told that's true i don't think it's
helped me know what matters
uh i'm as distant from my family as ever
um but i'm broken inside
diego i'm terribly broken inside
to be honest this it's it's quite sad to
see you
with the christmas tree the lights there
and no audience man
it's like normally you have people who
are laughing about your jokes but
i know i know it's like a rewarding you
can play
a recording of laughter people used to
go
to your show i have some tapes of people
laughing at my jokes from 1996.
so i'll start playing those those and
all the people laughing are now
they've all died of old age so we'll
you'll be coming from beyond the grave
um tell me about what it's like because
i would imagine
that the mexican people take christmas
very very seriously how seriously do
they take it in mexico city
i mean it's just another event uh and a
chance to
to drink mezcal and have fun
no but it is a very religious country
and uh
and we take we call it the marathon
guadalupe
you know which basically starts the 12th
of december that we celebrate the the
the the
the virgin's day virgin of guadalupe
and it goes all the way to january you
know so it's basically a drinking
contest that doesn't stop
and party after party and and everybody
my birthday happens to be just
just in between you know the 29th of
december oh nice
it's a it's a it's a big holiday in
mexico
so you're basically saying you've never
been sober for your birthday
now and and i've i've always been alone
you know people are with their families
or hangover or getting ready for new
year's eve
or somewhere else but but with me yeah
so
there's no it's impossible for someone
in mexico city a true mexican
to not indulge on the holidays you just
have to
you just everyone has to everyone has to
like i i did a documentary film
on a fantastic mexican boxer called
julio cesar chavez the biggest champion
and uh and he said to me one day in the
in on an interview that uh the first
time he lost
it was because don king could put him to
fight in
the first weeks of january and he was
like you cannot do that
and the biggest record you know of the
unbeaten
champion 88 or 89 fights professional
fights
was broken because because he was coming
out of the party i mean you received his
new year's eve come on no he lost his he
had the greatest record going in boxing
88 89 victories in a row but then
because he had to fight
in early january he lost just because he
had been partying
but but he says in the documentary i
told don king you know
he was even mad not at himself but don
king
for programming fight in january
but not to himself that he couldn't stop
that
that year from going to the party and i
think we all understand that we go like
yeah i mean what was he thinking
yeah he fought that guy again like
weeks later and beated him in one round
he was clearly
so that's my new plan i'm going to
challenge mexico's greatest champion
and i want it to take place on january
1st and you think maybe i have a chance
of winning
don't challenge canelo because i think
he doesn't drink
[Laughter]
okay well yeah i won't do that who do
you choose
i want to say uh your beloved in your
country are you getting used to the fact
and this is true
that many people are naming their
children after
you that must how does that feel
i thought it was after me but then i
understood it was a
about maradona you know we have that we
shared the same name and it wasn't me
you know but i thought it was you no no
sadly not uh but there's many comments
there
and i you know and i just i mean i'm
sorry for those kids
when they why would you feel sorry for a
a beautiful young mexican boy or girl
growing up with the name conan what a
proud heritage
yeah until they go onto youtube and find
out why
i mean
we're gonna see this video they're gonna
see the image of you with the bottle
like this that's everything they're
gonna have to see i'm a good role model
for all the children
[Laughter]
yeah there's uh no one's naming kids
after me it's not happening